as long as I'm mentioning things I got
on my birthday I get this uh official
document from uh Nassau County Executive
Bruce blakeman the guy's a a public
official with a big um document that
says whereas the county of Nassau Nassau
County on Long Island is proud to
recognize those outstanding individuals
who render significant contributions for
the enhancement of our region and the
betterment of our residents whereas
Howard Stern is such an
individual you Howard Stern have brought
entertainment to countless people around
the world with your boundary pushing
career and fearless approach to tackling
controversial topics your wit your humor
blah blah blah blah goes on and on the
county of Nassau is proud to extend a
commendation to you Howard Stern wow As
You Are are honored for your impressive
inspirational spirited leadership and
dedication and service to the
community Bruce a Blankman Nassau County
Executive I hereby give you a citation
on the occasion of Nassau County's 125th
anniversary it's some sort of Honor I
got that's like being kned by the queen
you got a
commentation I have a feeling uh you
know maybe he's referring to the fact I
was the first man to play piano with my
penis on the
air uh do you think you think that's
what put me over the top well he said it
was a groundbreaking or barrier breaking
career didn't not did he not I got an
honor I'm accepting
it thank you Nash County Executive you
got to tell your mother about this did
you tell her oh please one happened it
would take me an hour to explain it to
her she'd be like what what happened a
mama I got a citation oh for
parking